were you guys hoping to get to work
together again someday
yeah yeah for sure did wasn't really
expecting it you know you learn quick
enough
maybe in life but in this business as
well not to have too many expectations
you know but but hope I think hope stay
it keeps expectation from the door you
know so yeah it definitely wants to
embrugge with such a joy 14 years ago
whatever it was
um and to do it with this script this
story these characters Martin on the
west coast of of Ireland again it was
just it ticked boxes I didn't even know
I wanted ticked you know yeah yeah no it
was fantastic like I remember it was
kind of we we saw it ages ago we saw a
manifestation of it and then uh it it
came back in a much Fuller form and then
it was like gonna happen and then it was
a little bit delayed it was covered it
was all sorts of stuff and it was a it
was a terror for in my heart that we
wouldn't get to actually go there so
when we actually found her says on the
set it was an absolute thrill you know
it was like even better with the tease
if you know what I mean I remember you
seen the pope for the first time and
congratulate the market for it that was
lovely yeah because it was it made sense
his location just seeing the location
the pub before it was shot at the first
time and Brandon saw the pub and then
Martin came we were just having a look
we weren't shooting that day it was
during rehearsed so we were just going
to see the pope and have a little look
at the layout and this fellow walks up
to Mark and says congratulations to him
for the pub because it was the kind of
thing that was congratulations where the
cheek of them to put that Pub like I I
went I drove back to Apple where that
Pub was set six weeks after we shot with
my youngest son and uh and it was gone
ah quite sad yeah there was just gravel
just gravel but to put the pub at that
that corner that piece of land where the
Earth met the Atlantic and the waves
that were crashing there was a fury that
you felt that all the characters in the
film kind of understood but they
suppressed you know I was like Martin
goes to the edge and it was yes
this was the edge and he went there ah
yeah it was fantastic
uh did anything surprise uh either of
you about working together again was
there something that you know uh
compared to last time
for me not really just you know
obviously there was a maturity in terms
of the different stages of Life yeah but
not surprised that this father had moved
into that stage of life without losing
any of what he had In Bruges so it was
there was no it was a kind of an odd
familiarity really about the whole thing
but it was just it it's like seeing you
know somebody I haven't seen a little
bit and said oh you know that's
somehow life is uh happening in a
natural way yeah it was more the same
but different you know yeah yeah lovely
it was so we honestly got the old thing
about picking up where you left off
there was a lot of that there and a lot
of water under the bridge a lot of Life
lived you know people had died that we
loved people and kids have been born all
that kind of stuff but some kind of
essential essential element that allowed
those things to come into being that
remained the same that we we met each
other at yeah
um you know the film it's getting so far
really good reviews obviously there's
talk of you know the awards persuasion
did you guys pay attention to that kind
of stuff or is it just sort of like
aware of us you're aware of it I mean
it's more of the idea that the film
travels for me it's like you do all this
work it was a dream job with a dream
cast with a dream piece of work to do in
a dream location with dream weather we
get it done and ultimately the reason
for it all was that it crossed the line
into people's you know uh Consciousness
or into their so it it isn't a very
specific place and I know from having
explored stories and we know that it can
hear it sometimes just doesn't travel so
the big thing was when it seems to be
working for people is huge I mean we
went to Venice and the thing you know
Carl got best actor which is like joyful
so the awards thing is like that's a
pure joy yeah screenwriter and it's like
pure joy but the thing with was in
Venice people were laughing at like the
subtitles were up but people were
laughing on the line they were like it
was this connection was so real uh so
across the kind of various accents and
things like that but also like actually
just reading these things so that's the
film The Joy of it was that what the
warmth element yeah totally totally yeah
that communal experience because that's
what you're doing you know what I mean I
mean one of the one of those it's been a
long time since I've tried the boards
but one of the most beautiful things
about theater is that there is an
immediate relationship with the audience
right that's the most obvious thing you
lose to in film so then the odd time and
it happens maybe
geez if you do two or three films a year
you'd be looking for one of them to but
to be in a room and feel the audience
have a relationship to the story that
just all brought to life I mean all he
is in front of and behind the camera
it's a very humbling thing I I don't
know how I don't know how some actors
end up really cocky because to me it
feels really humbling it's kind of like
Jesus there's nothing I can do in a life
that would justify the kind of gift that
this experience is you know being in
that room in Venice was powerful it was
fantastic but like the thing is there's
a kind of there's an interesting thing
about it because
I I always you know with regard to
Awards and all that kind of stuff you
know I've lost more than it won't put it
that way the same as most people but
it's like
in the end if it I decided never to
second guess an award if it happens that
you win it you celebrate with Oliver but
if you don't get it you don't need it
for validation no and like the thing
about it is also in terms of the
audience though if you if we I decided
to remember saying after that thing if
you know if this doesn't work
there's a part of me that could care
less because the process and then the
actual experience of making it and the
aspiration behind it but I do want it to
work yeah and I was nervous that it
might I would want the best for it
and but when I was prepared that it
wouldn't travel yeah when it actually
travels it's just thrilling the game
that keeps on giving it's the gift that
keeps on giving but the gift was more
than enough before that exactly more
than enough like honestly the experience
of in the doing the whole in the doing
thing is where it really lives the rest
of the stuff just allows you another
deeply felt thank you and a bear with a
head from the bottom of your heart
honest to God yeah and I knew that some
people would get it I knew that
definitely I know enough we know enough
to know what's good and I knew some
people would get it
uh but the fact that it went across into
the people you weren't sure about yeah
yeah